don't get up should I explain to you the meaning
of a closed door and a whorehouse brother don't
leave me alone with these people I'm sorry
I've begun the feast a bit early and this is
the first of many courses the wintry abode of
the White Walkers tell me you're not thinking
of taking the black and go celibate the [__]
would go begging from Dorne to Casterly Rock
no I just want to stand on top of the wall and
piss off the edge of the world not eating what
is no one eating my wife wastes away and my
brother starves himself I'm not hungry you
lost the hand not a stomach how can I protect the
King right hardly wipe my own ass you're the Lord
Commander come on let others do the fighting
I was change a wooden post covered in my own
[__] for months is that supposed to make me
feel better maybe a bit so how is our sister how
do you think the son died our moms her son the
Kingslayer brothers you like it I like it keep
your mouth shut no more outbursts I kill you all
you're the golden son you could kill a king lose
a hand [__] your own sister you'll always be
the golden careful I'm the last friend you've
got I survived one trial by combat even though
you weren't there to save me I can't save you
this time either even if you lose imagine the
look on Father's face when you fall our family
name snuffed out with a single swing of the sword
tis tempting deciding a man's guilt or innocence
in the eyes of the gods by having two other men
hack each other to pieces tells you something
about the goals fratricide is brothers bit aside
his son crushing beetles with a rock Oh get on
with it you son of a hole is that any way to
speak about our mother Jaime thank you my life
curry now father would have been proud don't
talk about father listen to no one's talk bran
but if I ever saw you again I'd cut you enough
it'll take you a while with a sparring sold she
thinks I was an idiot to trust you unless of
people seem to think that actually I'm about
to step into a room with the most murderous
woman in the world who's already tried to
kill me twice that I know of who's in it yet
it'll be too hard on yourself he's fooled me
more than anybody what she never fooled you
you always knew exactly what she was they
loved her anyway I always pictured myself dying
in my own bed the age of 80 the belly full of
wine and girl's mouth around my [__] I wish
father were here I would love to see the look
on his face when he realizes his two sons are
about to die defending Winterfell it was all so
simple it wasn't so simple I was sleeping with
my sister and you had one friend in the world
who was sleeping with his sister I was speaking
in relative terms the perils of self-betterment
you were married before Sansa drink you're
a virgin that's a statement about the press
and no point in the past up until this very
moment have you slept with a man or a woman
[Applause] say something snide I'm happy
that you'll finally have to climb for it
do you know how long I've waited to till
talkers and jokes to climbing mountains to
climbing mountains if it weren't for you I
never would have survived my childhood you
would have you are the only one we didn't
treat me like a monster you were all I had
hmm [Music]